here's my message to President Trump
ahead of his meeting with president G
continue to proceed
full steam ahead with what's working
when it comes to tariffs do not settle
for an uneven deal I know he's smart and
but he has a lot of people from Wall
Street goldman morgan stanley all those
people pushing him on this china has
done literally nothing to earn a
reprieve from these scheduled tariffs
china said they'll do better where's the
evidence
remember what president reagan said
about the soviets and it came to
military issues of course a big one was
trust but verify remember mr. president
you won because of Main Street not
really Wall Street here with reaction is
Stephen Yeates China expert former
deputy national security adviser for
Vice President Dick Cheney and Robert
wolf former UBS chairman and Obama
economic advisor all right Robert you
are of the mind that we need a slightly
more mm well softer approach to China
when it comes to the at least the
threats of tariffs why I would say it a
little differently I would say one I
would argue I'm more forceful I would
have stayed with TPP that's trading with
the 11 Nations X China the best way to
attack China is actually to trade around
them secondly I think it's all about
intellectual property and patent
protection I would be much tougher on
things like economic espionage and
getting the FTC involved with respect to
tariffs I just don't think that's a good
policy because actually the one who
loses loses the most are our consumers
because the tariffs get passed on to us
as taxes and higher cost of goods so I
don't think that that's a great scrap
although it's been working that's the
that's the line you've recited pretty
much kind of the internationalist line
on dealing with China here's the problem
with that is that if all of these things
were the way to go then why didn't
Clinton do them why didn't Obama do them
why didn't butcher them why year after
year after year did we have an expanding
trade deficit with China and they became
more bold more aggressive and frankly
more vicious and how they ran their
trade regime how they dealt with us
openes little company up and not little
but a company up in minute Minnesota was
giving you example camrea they do quartz
countertops they just got a decision I
think it was at the International Trade
Court against what China had been doing
quartz countertops they ripped off all
their designs put cheap product into the
United States probably toxic and we have
real jobs on the line in Minnesota real
jobs
thankfully they won but they had the
money to fight most companies just give
up then have the money to fight this so
if all these things worked then why
didn't all these genius economists at in
the Obama administration say oh let's do
this well they tried a lot of it it
didn't work because China is is the big
dog on the field right now although in
the United States that's it okay well
there's a lot to take under the hood
there let me start with one TPP was
taken back by Trump it was actually
could have been because it was a TPP but
it was a loser Hillary the Chamber of
Commerce was forward you just made my
point for me if the chamber of Congress
okay yeah well Chamber of Commerce is
good no we won't the bottom line is for
American business when it's certain
businesses are able to send a lot of
work overseas I get that but it's not
been good which one's the common law or
tariffs of hammered agriculture which is
why we needed a bailout is that accurate
or not accurate I think we bailout our
own agricultural subsidies too much Ivan
I have an interesting point to make that
soybeans in a second so I'm glad you
raised that even let's go to you on this
because look I think Robert Robert does
represent a dominant view on Wall Street
they do a lot of business in Asia I
don't blame that I don't blame Wall
Street for wanting this at wanting a
more conciliatory approach to China
because Wall Street got really really
rich as middle America lost millions and
millions and millions of jobs and we
bled about what eight trillion dollars
from the US economy because of these bad
scenarios with China but I don't really
blame Wall Street I blame the US
government well it is our responsibility
to protect our own interests and it's
it's taken kind of a shock agent like
Donald Trump to remind everybody
about that being the primary mission of
our government and when we go into these
negotiations it's not to help make life
better for the Chinese people that might
be nice
secondary consequence if they're looking
to improve their livelihoods its to
improve the better improve the
livelihood of American workers consumers
all those interests but this has been
part and parcel of a longtime theory
that's been at the heart of China policy
that has as believed that if we've
brought China into the global systems
that it would normalize their behavior
and our differences would narrow and
that we would be have greater access to
their markets but even if you just take
the tariff questions they still have
wildly high tariffs in key areas and the
WTO has that see many no impact on that
and behind the scenes there it's not
just Americans who broadly think a
change in course was called for a lot of
our allies even Europeans are now and
even others at the g20 from latin
america are saying you know we want
President Trump to hold firm on this
because there needs to be a reset and
how China thinks it can engage the world
it's gotten away with too much for too
long all right Robert do you think in
the end Trump will back off on these
tariffs the increased tariffs that would
kick in January first I think not I
think that I don't think there'll be a
real agreement coming out of it I think
that but a pause I think there'll be a
pause probably for three months and say
we have negotiations the market will
love that he'll feel really good about
the market loving that with what the
feds kind of said recently going into
Christmastime so I actually think he'll
allow the pause but I think you'll hear
the rhetoric starting literally January
2nd that's funny on the soybeans
question around of time but yeah US
soybean exports to China are down 98
percent it's a big hit this year and the
markets wobbled the damage became clear
to that industry but the political
fallout that China anticipated this is
from the new Business Week piece tonight
yep never never materialized in
Republicans lost a net total of one seat
in in Kansas which is soybean country
one seat
yeah but can I just got to play the
other side but on that leave the blue
wall they lost Michigan Wisconsin and
Pennsylvania but it wasn't China the
China tariffs are popular there but the
auto sector it hasn't been all right
guys thanks so much